[Music]
all right today's question comes from
becky in pennsylvania becky writes i
found out six weeks ago that my husband
has been cheating on me for most of our
marriage i confronted him about this and
we're both seeing counselors at our
church
my husband is very repentant and
realizes he needs help we sold our small
business changed his phone number and
email he took a pay cut by taking a new
job where he has accountability and is
not working by himself
last night we tried to do our budget
meeting and it did not end well
i feel like he's very controlling in our
finances and i don't trust him at all
yet
should we dip into our emergency fund to
help pay for the counseling or use the
money from selling the business to help
us get through this time
whoo dave what
you go first
nope i'll go first i feel like something
i feel like this blew up and they
responded to a blow up with another blow
up and they're making a bunch of real
quick snap decisions
and they're sprinting and sprinting
trying to catch up with a problem they
just need to stop for a minute turn all
the lights on and say hey that that
party is over we need to figure out
where we're at
yeah
um
okay
yeah that would not be a bad first step
and yes you spend money on counseling
before you spend money on hanging on
you're not gonna have to hang on he got
a job shut up
you can hang on um
so
what i look for in these things and
sadly
in doing financial coaching one-on-one
trying to do the budget and you just
can't get the budget to work
and you can't get them to work together
and the more you force into it the more
you figure out something is going on
that's not showing up here on the paper
it's hard to put girlfriend as a line
item in a budget
yes it really doesn't work well and when
you actually have money going out over
here to secret life
then your budget's not going to balance
and if you're controlling
and you're having a power play on the
budget
i'm always suspicious
that
he's not back to his old tricks um
gotcha that's why he blew up gotcha
because she was calling him out because
the money's not the money's not showing
up where's the money and girlfriend's
not an acceptable line on the budget uh
for most wives huh you know for most
you know it just doesn't it doesn't it
doesn't work for most people so
um that's uh uh
yeah and so usually when
someone particularly the husband is
extremely controlling
on the money
there's other control issues in the
relationship there's other deceptions in
the relationship there's other things it
can be the la the wife too if she's just
an overbearing
test pilot for a broom factory
same thing going on right i read that
this way that he got busted it's a big
deal it all blows up and the response
was well then we're selling everything
you're getting a new job you're doing
this you're doing this you're doing this
you're doing this and he kind of got to
the end of it and he got he goes i've
repented enough i'm not i'm not but it's
over the budget right
well the budgetary controlling of our
finances that i'm just i don't know
we're reading it we're reading into an
email we don't have any idea but it
reminds me of it reminds me of you know
high school
in an english class you can kind of get
to your answer
math class it was
there was one right answer and you can
it's not an essay question all right you
can fudge your way through now we're on
the same page we're doing good we're
doing good that budget says are you in
are you out and neither of them i don't
think are in here
yeah
neither of them she's got yes to answer
your question you can't afford
let's spend a little bit of money on
counseling before we spend a lot of
money on divorce court i agree
so yes i agreed and spent a little bit
of money on counseling and you won't
even miss it because everything else
will start to work right if the
counseling is working right right so um
i feel like he's very controlling
warning sign i do not trust him at all
yet well you shouldn't right yet
uh the way trust is recovered is with uh
lengthy periods of time of being
trustworthy right
worthy of trust right now what we have
is a lengthy period of time of not being
worthy of trust and you would be insane
just you would be insane to trust him he
hasn't been trustworthy his whole this
whole name that's what i mean yeah so
why would you suddenly start trusting
him because he repented and that we went
to two counseling sessions of the church
no you wouldn't be you wouldn't be a
sane human being if you trusted him
based on that it takes a little while to
recover that and the old marriage you
had is over period well you didn't
really have one right you didn't have
one but what you thought was yours over
the way forward is the fantasy you
thought you had not to get back to what
you had you got to recreate something
new you got to reimagine it re-envision
it rebuild something new you could do it
together and make it strong and
beautiful and great and wonderful all
those things but you got to know we're
going this way we're not going to be
able to reclaim what was so i'll tell
you this i feel like and i i'm old and
i've walked with a whole bunch of
friends and
other people uh through this process of
divorce and this process of bankruptcy
both and i tell people in both of those
instances i have never with the
exception of domestic violence i have
never told someone you need to get a
divorce
uh and i've never told someone they need
to file bankruptcy uh because i don't
want them following and go because dave
ramsey said
no you need to make that's a big girl
big boy decision you make on your own
not because somebody told you and made
it okay that's right uh and the only
thing i will tell you on either one
both are life-changing
tragedies
and anyone who minimizes either
is full of crap
they're both horrible to go through
bankruptcy divorce
so
that's one of the reasons i don't give
people the dave ramsey permission to do
that you get to make your own permission
i'll still be your friend if you go
through it i'm not gonna be mad at you
but uh you're not gonna do it because i
said
uh i'm gonna give you that authority so
you have to make your own big girl and
then the other thing i always tell you
is
if you get to the end of this and you
have done
everything you can try
and then one more thing
you won't live with regret right
i look back on filing bankruptcy
almost 30 years ago now
and i'm not proud of it it is still a
mark of shame
but as a 28 year old kid
at the time after fighting it for two
and a half years my tank was empty
intellectually spiritually emotionally i
got babies in the house i was scared i
didn't know what to do i had done
everything i knew to do and then i
waited another two months
and so i don't look back on that and go
that guy was weak of character and just
walked out i did everything i knew how
to do my level of regret for that is
almost zero right so my ability to
forgive myself and move on is really
high that's right and that's what you
want if you're going to do with this
divorce you want to have tried
everything so yes try the counseling yes
try to meet with the church yes try all
that but bozo's got a long track record
of being a bozo here right he's not an
honest person hasn't it it's not you
know so you got a long hill to climb
for him to be trustworthy and for you to
trust him
and uh very controlling over our
finances warning warning warning
[Music]
just reading between the lines on an
email
that's what we do here
on the ramsay show